welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid Sergent para manic and we are many
73 aka Michael both ask why is why these
might have one of the universal image
limits a good question let's answer it
first of all light isn't the only thing
that goes that fast anything without
mass will go that fast it just so
happened to the making of this video
light is the only thing we've observed
to be massless there are some
theoretical particles without mass and
we're pretty sure most of them are there
because the models work great but we've
never actually seen them secondly in my
e equals mc-squared video I mentioned
the speed of light really isn't all that
special but you said it's the same for
everything everywhere at any time yeah
but it's not the only thing like that
the point is it's just a number about
300 million meters per second but that's
only when you use standard units meters
for space and seconds for time in the US
you might say 186,000 miles per second
or 670 million miles per hour or in
Canada you might say 1.1 billion
kilometers per hour units are kind of
arbitrary I mean you could just as
easily measure both space and time in
meters and the speed of light would be
one
in fact that's what most physicists
working with the stuff actually do they
treat it like it's just a conversion
factor between the units we've chosen
for space and the unit's we've chosen
for time weird huh anyway let's take a
look at what would actually happen if
someone were to accelerate toward the
speed of light and how exactly do you
expect to do that with my excel or o
matic
obviously now I know I put this thing in
here somewhere
aha here it is we'll turn this on we'll
put it right in here and let's not
forget the relativity compensator on the
camera and Rauf as I start to speed up
not much happens it just looks like I'm
going fast the most I'll notice is an
apparent force of gravity toward the
back of my bubble but my excelling
romatic keeps that from getting too
strong things don't get interesting
until I get to about 10 percent the
speed of light I won't notice anything
but everyone else will see several
things one time will pass slower for me
- I'll compress along the direction that
I'm moving and three I'll be more
attracted to the earth because my mass
will appear larger the larger mass also
increases my inertia meaning it's
getting harder and harder to accelerate
me the faster I go the more quickly my
Exelero matic battery is drained until
it finally runs out of power oh so yeah
as you get closer and closer to the
speed of light the energy needed to make
you go faster is higher and higher you
need an infinite amount of energy just
to get to the speed of light and as far
as we know nothing in this universe is
infinite so you couldn't even get to the
speed of light let alone pass it it's
just not physically possible
something like light doesn't have to
worry about this problem no mass means
no inertia so not only can it go that
fast it has to go that fast so what
would you do if you got your hands on my
excel or o matic please share in the
comments and until next time remember
it's okay to be a little crazy
you